欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们接着来讲我们店铺的目标国家市场要怎么样去选
为什么要去选我们的目标市场
因为通过选国家能够判断出我们这个市场的一个潜力
以及我们这个店铺或者是说我们这个品类的产品是否有增量
如果我们店铺都没有增量
那么是不是就会导致我们很难去成交客户
同时呢往前倒一点就是很难去获得流量
流量都难获取了
成交就更加难了
所以说我们一定要明确我们的目标市场是哪些
另外一个情况就是我们经常听说
我们全球都做我们的产品能够全球卖
是这个没错
这个产品是能全球卖
但是你如果按照全球卖的思路去做推广
去选品类
去选择对应的产品的风格款式
那么你会发现你的范围太广
最终导致你的时间精力
还有你的直通车的预算有限的情况下
你很难达到一个比较满意的一个流样状态
就会导致你好像每个国家都有一点点
有点点流量, 都有一点点循环, 没有成交
我们做店铺的目的是什么?
就是为了达成成交
然后获得更多的客户
持续的让我们的店铺经营下去
所以我们一定要明确我们目标的国家
从小的范围去切入
因为可能你的产品是全球做的
但是能够给你贡献你的交易额80%以上的
可能大概三到五个国家就贡献了这么多交易额
所以我们要先选对国家
然后再从这些国家维度去努力
那么是不是事半功倍
好过你每天都在无头绪的去摸索
那么接下来我们来看一下
我们怎么样去选择目标的国家
之前我们课程也有讲过
关于如何去选择国家市场
那么这里我们是给出一些
比较具有时操性的一些方向跟思路
首先第一个我们要在市场参谋里面
去找到查行业选择类目
通过这个维度去选择我们的目标国家
首先你看我这截图
从这个市场参谋里面去选
选择了国家之后
最后面获得这些国家
国家了之后
我们把这些什么国家的数据去统计出来
放到ECL表格里面
再把交易买家的数据也统计出来
放到我们的一个表格里面去
降续排列
我们就知道
我们的一个
寻盘买家跟交易买家
都在哪一些国家里面有更多的客户
那么我们前期没有任何数据基础的店铺的时候
我们就优先参考这些国家去主攻
那么再通过数据的维度去判断
我们要放弃哪些国家
选择哪些国家
继续去提升我们整个店铺的一个效果
所以这里选择的这些国家
一个给我们用于营销推广
也就是直通车推广的时候
锁定目标国家
第二个维度就是能够通过这些国家
我要去选择什么样的产品类型去推广
因为你知道了这些国家之后
你就要去选这些国家偏好的产品
然后再去推广
才会获得更好的效果
那么第二个维度就是要从买家参谋
到行业买家这个里面
这个维度去选择我们的目标国家
这个维度一定要重视以订单买家的国家为重点参考
因为很多时候我们可能去看一些什么访问买家
以及寻盘TM买家为主
但是这些买家虽然说多
但是他并不代表着说你的这个订单买家就一定多
所以我们一定要分清主次
你看我们选了上面的这些维度之后
这里是不是出现这些国家维度
这里也有一些国家的数据
这些国家我们也是按照一样的逻辑去统计到表格
选择有交集的国家就可以了
那么也是用于推广
还有就是去选产品
接下来我们就到后台去实操一下
让大家更加清晰的理解和应用
首先我们打开的是市场探谋到我们想要选的内幕
先选内幕
选完内幕之后进来之后
我们看到这里有个商机分析
商机分析里面有一个买家分析
这里买家分析是不是会有两个维度
我们重点参考就是寻盘买家
还有就是交易的买家
那么这两个维度选择了之后
它对应的这边这个板块往下拉
比如说我们选择寻盘买家
选择寻盘买家之后往下拉
把这些国家复制出来
这些国家复制出来
就是寻盘的偏好买家的国家
这个把再选一下交易买家
那么交易买家之后
这里就会变成交易买家偏好的
这些国家
我们把这两个都复制出来
放到表格里面
然后去选择他们有交集的国家
确定多少个国家
我们通常来确定
前期确定这里有20个国家
那么我们前期可能确定10到15个国家
可以先优先考虑
然后再通过这些国家
测出来的数据再缩减一下
大概可能到时候就是8到10个国家
或者是说还是维持这些国家
到时候你要看
具体的数据的转化效果
才能够最终决定
这里关于你选择多少个国家的话
没有一个说标准
但是呢最好就是
你尽可能的在有限的资源里面去找到
相对少的那些高转化的国家就可以了
这里的话你要灵活一点
不需要固定10个15个
这些没有条条框框限制自己
你一定要灵活一点
那第二个维度我们可以从
买家参谋这里一定是去看行业买家的
行业买家这里的数据维度我们可以选
30天啊90天这些大一点的维度
废幕的话你要选相对来说细分一点点的废幕
这里选什么?主要以订单买家为主
往下拉
你看这里是不是这些国家的一个分布
你去把内幕选好了
把订单买家, 群盘买家, 贴母买家的这三个数据维度
三个数据维度去复制到表格
找到他们的交集
保留大概10到20个国家
再进行一个测试
测完了之后呢
我们再缩减一些国家就可以了
比如说5个到10个国家
去看一下这些国家的转化率
我们也可以根据我们选择出的这些国家
去选择产品的类型和款式
去进行一个推广
那么我们是不是产品更加符合这些国家
那么是不是可能效果会更好一点
所以这些维度都能够帮助我们
细致的去选择目标的市场
以及我们的产品的类型
至于数据的标准
不要被调调框所限制
一定要灵活一点点就可以了
这个就是关于我们店铺
一定要选择目标市场
去精准的推广
把资源集中起来去应用
这样才能够让我们的店铺更快的成长起来
大家一定要重视去行动
好了这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见